es ist soweit der beginn der zivilen
raumfahrt oder anders gesagt in diesem
jahr wird es zum ersten mal regelmäßige
reisen für touristen in den weltraum
geben das ist wirklich der absolute
hammer es geht wirklich los ob wir jetzt
schon alle bald zum mond oder mars
fliegen können klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen endlich ist es
soweit virgin galactic epd in den
weltraum ab jetzt ist das erste
unternehmen das damit regelmäßige flüge
in den weltraum für touristen anbieten
wird und das war keine absolute
erfolgsgeschichte denn eigentlich sollte
dieser menschheitstraum schon viel
früher war werden doch es gab
rückschläge dramatische unfälle bei
einem testflug vor drei jahren mit der
vss enterprise dem virgin starship
enterprise gab es eine fehlbedienung das
raumschiff stürzte ab und der co pilot
starb und der pilot wurde schwer
verletzt das ganze programm musste
umgestellt werden und das raumschiff an
einem entscheidenden punkt neu
konstruiert werden damit das nicht mehr
passieren kann schon davor kamen beim
triebwerks des 2007 drei techniker ums
leben doch 2014 führte ein tragischer
fehler des co piloten michael als marie
zum auseinanderbrechen des space chips
für die rückkehr zur erde ohne antrieb
verfügt das schiff über ein federsystem
dass die flügel nach oben klappt es muss
entsichert und aktiviert werden co pilot
michael elster entsicherte es zu früh
und durch die starke strömung am schiff
wurde es aufgelöst und zerriss das
raumschiff seitdem ging es mit virgin
galactic nur sehr langsam vorwärts doch
jetzt wagt eigentümer richard branson
den ersten flug genau am 20 juli 2009 10
zum fünfzigsten jahrestag der apollo
landung auf dem mond soll es soweit sein
der startschuss für die zivilen
raumfahrt für die mit touristen bis
dahin sollen noch weitere testflüge
absolviert werden
der nächste start ist am 20 februar aber
schon im dezember 2018 ist ein flug in
den weltraum nach amerikanischer
definitionen in einer höhe von rund 82
kilometern gelungen künftige start
sollen aber auch internationale
standards erfüllt da beginnt der
weltraum in ein
100 kilometern höhe die reise wird
jeweils dreieinhalb stunden dauern und
sechs minuten davon befinden sich die
passagiere im weltraum sie können sich
abschnallen und schweben im raumschiff
der raumflug wird übrigens kein
schnäppchen die passagiere zahlen
jeweils 200.000 dollar für ein ticket
also und 176000 euro
na ja da muss eine alte oma lange
verstrickt mehr zur fundamentalen
bedeutung der raumfahrt gibt es hierbei
neugier zone unbedingt drauf klicken und
unbedingt abonnieren bis dann bleib dran